[Music]
michael
is in sacramento hey michael welcome to
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
hi dave um i've just got such a
predicament i've i'm 54 years old
i've got my primary residence
i've got so much credit debt i've got
about ten thousand credit card debt but
i probably have about
three hundred thousand dollars total in
non-mortgage debt
and i just feel like i'm spinning my
wheels and i don't know what to attack
first
i just i just feel lost what is the um
what is the other 290 000
the 290 000 is between student loans
uh lines of credit uh loans
that i had to take um when i got
divorced about
12 years ago to um i had a house that
we were gonna it was we you're trying to
sell and i
told the bank that if you let me sell
this and not go to foreclosure
i will take on that loan as a personal
debt because
i pay my bills so i did that and i've
been
paying on that ever since so um and then
a variety of other ones how much is that
going on
that loan is fifty thousand dollars at
four percent okay
and how much is a student student loan
is uh
sixty seven thousand and the cars are
what
the cars total uh ninety
yeah ninety thousand two cars and what's
your household income
uh 170 salary and then i just recently
had an opportunity which i started to
make an extra 3 500 a month
okay over time that's going to be
consistent excellent so 210 i
have a pension and and what is your home
worth
my home is worth uh 900 000
and i owe uh sale
575 on it what do you do for a living
and i have two rental properties
i'm a physician assistant okay and you
have two rental properties in that and
what are they worth
uh see i have one in montana that's
worth uh
300 310 000 and i owe 230
000 on and i have one in idaho that's
worth
uh 325 000 and i owe 330 on it
and then i have a pension of 600 000
that i can have once i'm selling 11
years
or i can take that lump sum or i can
take 3 000 a month
annuity okay
so um
how much do you want to be out of this
mess really bad or just
or it's just sort of bothering you no
i've lived like this my entire life and
when i got divorced i mean
the other part are you ready to get your
life back
i i've been ready for a while because
you need to really be ready because i'm
getting ready to sell everything in your
life
i'm i'm ready i mean sell both rental
properties in both cars this week
so sell all three properties no they're
both rental
properties and both cars yeah
okay all right
get you two five thousand dollar cars
you make two hundred ten thousand
dollars
so now you have now you have um
you have your home and uh you will have
210 000 left minus so you're gonna have
about 150
000 left in debt and you make 210 and
you're going to pay that off in two
years
the only problem is i just got these
properties six months or a few months
ago and out there on a 1031 exchange
i don't care and i'm going to be taxed
heavily i don't care doesn't matter
all right your life sucks you're
drowning man
yeah you have so much crap in your life
that is not producing joy
well if i can tell you one more thing
i've got an alimony of 2
000 a month that's never going to go
away until i die
okay that's twenty four thousand dollars
out of 210. that doesn't keep us from
getting out of debt
right so 24 and 75 is 100 out of 210
you're going to live on 210 and you're
going to be debt-free in two years and
you're going to sell everything
except your personal residence okay so
if i listen
i'll tell you what i'm reacting to i'm
reacting to the tone of your voice
when you called in you sounded so
overwhelmed so despondent so stuck
that it sounded to me like you were
willing to do almost anything
and that's where i am that's where i am
i think you should do
i think you should feel that way because
you feel like this 12 freaking years
this stuff's been hanging around your
neck
and you make all this money and you're a
pa and you can't get
traction you are so freaking stuck it's
unbelievable
and you can't breathe and that's what i
heard did i miss something
nope you nailed it and every time you
walk into that hospital to help other
people you've got 14 cinderblocks in
your own backpack is that fair
yeah at least brother you got to set
that pack down
you got a bunch of crap in your life man
put it down man
just stuff 90 000 worth of cars
yeah jesus who who are you
who are you impressing man i know i'm
not asking that in a jerk way but
there's something in you that says i
need a million plus dollar house
and these well i mean he's in sacramento
yeah that's a 3-2 and two expensive cars
and
two homes that something's telling you
that you're not good enough man
what is it yeah you know that this
didn't happen all at once
this has been you've this has been death
by a thousand cuts layer upon layer upon
layer
this stuff is built up and then it never
goes away so it's a cumulative effect as
well
i'll solve it 12 years ago thing we got
a student loan that's still hanging
around after all these years
we then we go buy cars and now we roll
these houses into a 1031
so you're gonna get hammered on taxes
out the backside so you're gonna have
100 000
in taxes probably yeah i'm gonna have a
lot
15 of what what was your what do you
think your gain is that you rolled into
these
my gain will probably uh because i put
uh eighty thousand down on one and
seventy thousand down on you that's not
what you put down has nothing to do with
the calculation of your gain how much
capital gains did you roll into this
1031
i was i was told my taxes will be uh if
i were to cash out about fifty thousand
dollars okay good that's right
less than i thought that pretty good
it's only 50 grand
this is the price of cleaning up your
life
yes so i you know basically you're going
to get enough out of these properties to
pay your taxes
and be free so that's a wash we're going
to sell the cars for close to a wash
and so now you have two hundred and ten
thousand dollars left
i was wrong earlier it's not 150 because
of the capital gains bill
i said 160 150 but it's going to be 210
i didn't have a 50 000 capital gains
bill in there but now i do
so you're you're still you know so how
fast do you pay off 210 making 210.
three years at 70 grand
okay and that means you have 200 it
means you have 110 000
to live on after you pay alimony and 70
grand towards debt for three years and
you're 100 debt free how old are you
54. you won't be debt free when you're
57 this is how you do it
okay i just want to make sure i
understand so both cars sell both rental
properties
and then hit your plan hard
nothing else complete focus
like i'm so pissed off i am so sick and
tired of being sick and tired
that i have not only sold this stuff i'm
gonna sell two of the kids if they don't
hide
i'm just gonna have to get my wife to
buy in hopefully i won't be too hard
yeah well i mean does she want her life
back ask her if she wants a husband that
can
sleep a full night of sleep can breathe
yeah a husband that can walk around the
neighborhood without his head spinning
without having to grab his phone every
two seconds
yeah they can wake up with a smile on
his face
we call it financial peace that's what
we call it
and you can do this man you can do it
but it's just a matter of if you want to
if you get sick and tired of being sick
and tired that's when you change your
life man
if you can get through pa school and if
every day you can walk into that
traumatic situation and heal people
you can do this i know you can't do it
just are you
ready to be willing to go because
there's a completely different
groove we're going to plow down the
middle of your brain
yeah to get your brain to function
differently because you've been running
through you've been running the great
american mess and if
your wife can contribute to this too you
can get done even faster yeah we
yeah yeah so i mean the only thing i did
only thing i did to her sell her car
that's all i did and her montana house i
guess but oh well you're costing us the
idaho house dave but
oh well z yeah that's that don't mean
dave ramsey guy